This is the grill for you. I call it "The Obama".
Come on, se llamo, me llamo, good Pitbull.
I call this "The Big Black Machine".
Lisa, you're the best thing that ever happened to me.
Oh my God.
Do you smell gas?
A little bit came out, but I wasn't nervous. That was just a creeper.
Oh, no, not, umm...
I got thirteen-degree burns on my ass.
You're the best salesman I've ever seen.
I can see you being a stockbroker like me.
- Can't you give me a job?
I wish I could, my bosses won't let me hire a dropout.
- Look at Mark Zuckerberg.
He dropped out of Harvard. You dropped out of Piedmont High.
I was a couple credits shy of graduating.
I got to get my GED.
- I'm the principal of this school. I can do whatever I want.
You're in... my... house.
Are you using a black voice?
- No I don't hear color.
Alright, let's do some introductions. My name is Carrie.
I'm here to make a little extra cash so that I can afford this warrant that I got, but that's none of your business.
Welcome to Night School.
This book is kind of thick. I thought it'd be more like a leaflet.
If you're not gonna do the work drop the class.
No, I'mma do the work. You'll see.
We'll see. - Yes, we will. - Great!
- Superb! - Excellent! - Good!
You're gonna be a financial analyst?
-I am, and it starts immediately.
I have been waiting on the Lord to bring me a pint-sized little man who can fill this out.
Let me get you chicken from the Lord!
You take that test or I'll tenderize your ass.
I will beat you.
Are you trying to get your GED?
Are you trying to get your GED?!
- Yes.
You can get out my way, bitch.
My suspicions were correct.
Boom!
- You're clinically dumb.
There is no cure for what you have.
- Oh my God! I got learning herpes. I got the gift that people give it... - Boy...
You did the black voice thing with him?
- It's not a black voice, not a black voice.
You don't remember when you was in that meeting you was like
"We gonna get it lit up in here, this meeting lit."
- It was very lit.
"I keep it 100".
- When have I ever not kept it 100?
You